[Musique]
entre deux averses vous pouvez peut-être
expérimenter une nouvelle invention le
barbecue solaire cet appareil nous vient
pas du midi mais de lorraine pas de
charbon ni d'allumettes c'est économique
et sur le reportage de fr3 nancy non ce
ne sont pas là les plans d'une antenne
parabolique recevant des images de
satellites c'est un barbecue solaire un
barbecue du nom que lui ont donné ses
inventeurs son fonctionnement est simple
à l'intérieur d'une coupole les rayons
du soleil sont concentrés sur une
surface où la température s'élève à près
de 750 degrés il fallait y penser
puisque c'est le principe des couverts
par archimède qui est ainsi adapté à
l'une de nos habitudes culinaires
estivale la parabole est un peu modifié
puisque l'on s'est aperçu que si on
utilisait vraiment une parabole parfaite
on chauffe et quant à un point donc
par exemple le rosbif des corps était
transpercé ou après c'est aussi ça
aurait été transpercée mais certainement
pas de suite
le système donc c'est une succession de
paraboles dans la 60 qui chauffe sur un
diamètre de 30 cm vérifications faites
ça marche voyait le sort que subissent
aussi des biftecks sous l'effet des
rayons solaires attention ça ébloui
mieux vaut mettre des lunettes de soleil
c'est d'ailleurs la seule précaution
d'emploi préconisé pour les cuisiniers
et leurs invités construit en matériaux
composites le barbecue n'existe pour
l'heure qu'à un seul exemplaire
expérimental prévu pour 12 personnes
mais les modèles pour 2 4 ou 8 personnes
seront aussi proposés son prix de 800 à
2500 francs pour l'instant car la
fabrication en série est bien sûr
l'objectif de ces inventeurs pour
baisser le prix de revient on espère
bien monter
une sarl
acheter du matériel naturellement
employer du personnel ce qui serait
vraiment notre vraiment notre but le
barbecue peut également servir de
tournebroche de chauffe eau ou de
générateurs électriques
alors fini les fumées des barbecues
classique les difficultés d'allumage les
risques de brûlure ou les dangers de
bresse volante pas du tout le barbecue
n'est pas tout à fait un concurrent de
ses cousins classique il est simple sûr
et propre certes mais il ne marche pas
la nuit et pour être efficace il lui
faut grand soleil égard au moindre nuage
[Musique]